I think we've all experienced those
synchronicities where you're thinking
about something or you have an intention
and all of a sudden you start to see
reality kind of conform itself around
you in some way and you're not going
anywhere to get it uh somehow it seems
to be coming to you and there's a very
direct correlation between energy and
reality so when you start to synchronize
your energy to a possibility that exists
in the quantum field and you have a
coherent brain there's a very very
specific signal that we can send out and
when we match that brain coherence with
heart coherence it is the heart that
acts as a magnet and draws the
experience back to us hey it's EV car
Michael and I watch these videos every
day because I need them for motivation
being around successful entrepreneurs
every morning helps me believe that I
can do great things too it's like your
morning coffee but for your goals
kickstarting your day with a blast of
positiv
so here is a challenge for you try
watching One video every morning for the
next 30 days and let's find out together
if they help you do great things too if
you're in leave a hash believe in the
comments below so I can celebrate with
you so the thought being electrical
charge and the feeling being the
magnetic charge and how you think and
how you feel broadcasts information into
the quantum field and I think whatever
we broadcast into the field is our
experiment with
Destiny so we either create from the
field or we create from matter and if we
create from matter as bodies local in
space and time and three-dimensional
reality we have to move through space to
get what we want we have to move back
and forth to work and drive there uh to
manifest our dreams and in creating in
three-dimensional reality takes time and
it takes energy sometimes uh people get
so lost in reality they forget what
their dream were because there's too
much time between cause the thought and
effect the experience and that's what
separation does in three-dimensional
reality creating from the field and
getting Beyond yourself your
associations to everything physical and
known and being able to enter through a
small door the eye of the needle the
quantum field passing through that eye
of the needle as pure Consciousness and
connecting to a field and teaching
people
how to create from the field instead of
from matter connected to that unified
field to Source energy when they create
from source and they're Connected To
Source and source is the cause that
creates matter the effect if we create
from Source connected to it from the
field instead of from matter we don't
have to go anywhere now to get what we
want we begin to draw the experiences to
us so by
combining heart coherence with with
brain coherence now we have a Wi-Fi
signal and all we have to do is
synchronize our energy to some intention
with some emotion and tune in to the
energy of the future and the longer
you're conscious of this energy the more
you draw your future to you and if you
keep practicing it every day it's going
to become familiar to you and all of a
sudden that will be your natural energy
and when you change your energy you
change your life and the more coherent
the signatures
electromagnetically the more refined The
Experience uh we have rule number two is
consume information mindfully with taus
wart Bieber that most of the
neuroscientists that I know all the ones
I know personally and other ones that
I've heard of don't watch the news or
read newspapers that's powerful and it's
not because we don't want to be informed
because obviously we do manage to stay
informed in other ways of important
events around the world but if you just
look at the nature of news the the
proportion of it that is bad news and
the impact that that has on your brain
is is
disproportionate so the first thing is
to curate your news feeds your social
media feeds so that you're not getting
bombarded with so much bad news and and
you balance that out for yourself of
course life can be
hard so yes you have to be resilient as
well but the first thing is to take
charge of of what you're actually
feeding your brain and that's everything
from your diet to information also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three is evolve your
Consciousness with eart tole many of the
existing
structures social structure that also
applies to economic structures the
structures in medical medicine
Psychiatry psychology
C
education school system University
system many of those structures they
were created by not by the awakened
Consciousness they they were all they've
all been around for a long time and they
evolved out of the egoic
Consciousness so many of the structors
are the products of
unenlightened states of
Consciousness they reflect the unlight
unawakened states of
Consciousness
so many of you will
find uh it
necessary to step out of sometimes as I
said they can May in certain cases they
can be changed from within if there are
enough people within who want to change
it but many structures are too rigid for
change so it is up to you to create new
structures that reflect your and come
together perhaps with others who are
also Awakening so that the new
structures will reflect your State of
Consciousness so this is what the world
needs the world cannot continue to
function within the old structures that
are product of un
unenlightened uh States Of Consciousness
the
economy the Pol itical system even here
in the states it seems to compare to
some other places functions quite well
but it's dysfunctional
too the economic structur certainly you
can see how dysfunctional they are the
educational system how children are
brought up all those things they require
new structures to reflect the rising
Consciousness so that's your job to
create those and here we come to that
part of manifestation which the universe
also wants it does not it wants you yes
of course it wants you to go within
realize who you are in your essence and
then from
there it also wants you
to create it wants you to manifest it
will use you it will work through you to
manifest new forms because the old forms
don't work
anymore so and that's a it's a wonderful
thing to to do that and you will see how
empowered you suddenly
become as you go about creating new
forms how powerful your abilities to
manifest will be if they are in
alignment with what the universe wants
with what the one Consciousness wants
they are not little egos wanting to
create something you are in alignment
with what the UN first needs right now
the the what the one The Awakening
Consciousness ons if you then start
manifesting from that deeper level
within
yourself you'll be amazed how empowered
you can be in your
manifestation sometimes there is a Time
Gap so sometimes manifestation happens
very quickly sometimes you need to to as
you
are
inspired a so to speak a
blueprint of what is possible of what
you or not so much you of what
Consciousness wants you to create may
arise in your mind and this this mental
blueprint of what you want to create
this may be there for a while it might
attract others with similar mental
blueprint and then at some point the
manifestation
begins some action may be necessary but
again the action that you take will be
inspired by the Consciousness and it
will not be
stressful this create this this is a new
way of
creating if stress comes in you're
falling back into the old
Consciousness this is a Joyful Way of
creating new forms and new structures in
this world rule number four is give
yourself permission to win with with Mel
Robins first of all you got to give
yourself permission to really have what
you want okay cuz you got to have the
thing that you're visualizing be
something that is authentically
something that you want number two you
must see yourself taking the steps the
tiny actions and doing the work that
will lead you to creating or having what
you want third you got to feel in your
body what it feels like to do the work
and you also have to feel feel Pride as
you see yourself doing the work because
that amplifies your mind body and spirit
really imprinting and training and
preparing for it and fourth uh obviously
you got to take the actions and all of
that manifesting and preparing inspires
you to take the actions but one place
where so many folks get stuck when they
start trying to make manifesting a daily
habit is you go and you know what you
want
but then you sit down and you try to
imagine what the steps are that you need
to take to get there and you don't have
a clue your mind goes blank if this is
you I'm so excited that you're watching
this because the simple trick based in
science is called the power of
objectivity all you got to do is stop
visualizing yourself and insert your
friend Mel Robbins or insert somebody
else that you love and admire and the
power of objectivity is going to
immediately switch you from a blocked
mind to one that is bolder and more
creative and able to visualize the steps
now I'm not just making this up there's
extraordinary research that was just
written about in the Harvard Business
School review they did eight different
studies at the University of Wisconsin
where they were studying the power of
objectivity and with thousands of
participants here's what they found when
participants tried to visualize
themselves doing hard things immediately
the participants when they thought about
themselves doing something hard like
let's just say asking for a raise okay I
want you to imagine yourself asking for
a raise or applying for that dream job
when you visualize yourself doing it you
immediately focus in on minutia you
start imagining all kinds of things that
could go wrong you start arguing against
yourself and doubt comes flooding in you
have a very cautious mindset when you
place yourself in those scenarios
however if you were to visualize me Mel
Robbins asking for that rise immediately
your mindset switches to being very bold
being creative seeing all kinds of
opportunities and in fact when you not
only visualize me your friend Mel
Robbins asking for that raise that you
want when you give me advice you're
super enthusiastic you're like Mel you
should go for it and I bet in your life
you have probably told friends or loved
ones you should ask for more money and
you mean it because you're visualizing
them but you yourself won't visualize
yourself doing that you talk yourself
out of it we've all had this experience
you yourself are probably sitting there
going you're right Mel I constantly tell
my friends you deserve more you should
break up with that jerk you should go
for it but when it comes to yourself you
see the excuses in death so I want you
to leverage not only this com sense but
this research to your advantage when it
comes to manifesting pick what you want
and then if your mind goes blank when it
comes to seeing yourself do the work
literally just insert your friend Mel
Robbins or insert anybody that you love
and R number five the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is rewire
your brain for wealth with John aser
when we talk about rewiring your brain
for wealth why do we even use the word
rewire our brain for wealth like it has
to assume that our brain is wired for
wealth right what does that even mean so
when we talk about rewiring your brain
for
wealth it assumes that there is a wiring
already there and the question then
becomes was the wiring there when you
and I were born were we born with any
beliefs were we born with an identity
were we born with a self-image or even a
self-concept were we born with any
attitudes were we born with any habits
were we born with any expectations were
we born with any Financial set points or
limitations right Financial glass
ceilings and the answer is no there was
there was there were brain cells 100
billion of them or so and over the
course of Our
Lifetime right uh each one of those
brain cells created neural connections
about
10,000 neural connections per cell so if
you want to do some math do 100 billion
times 10,000 huge number and those
connections started to formulate our
perspective our beliefs our Paradigm our
attitude our skills our expectations our
set points right so let's understand the
the nature of how our brain became
conditioned what the essence of this
wiring is so what happens is as we you
know are born into this environment with
parents with certain skills certain
knowledge um certain awarenesses um Etc
we also have to assume that
we apply or we we learned the stuff from
them about what's real and what isn't
right right we
learned everything from our environment
our parents the meaning we gave things
we learned if we went to school it means
this if we didn't it means that it means
that this job earns that Etc so we were
born with a complete open slate right
and then we created these neural
patterns and then those neural patterns
went from creation initially to being
what we call is
softwired soft soft wire which means the
neurons that formulated these
connections through effort and awareness
and the meanings we gave things became
softwired not just in the conscious mind
so we could declare the things that we
may believe but through our habits and
our paradigms and our attitude and also
the beliefs that we have about what's
possible you know for us right so when
we're talking about rewind wiring your
brain for
wealth is it possible that let's say if
you if you make whether it's $1,000 a
month or $1,000 a day it doesn't matter
that the more you've been earning that
amount of money that becomes your
financial or wealth set point the more
we reinforce a pattern does it not mean
that the pattern then reinforces self
through
automaticity which is one of the brain
ways to conserve energy right there's
neuroplasticity our brain's ability to
make
connections there's neurogenesis which
is our brain's ability to create new
neurons which we once thought wasn't
happening but it does but then
automaticity is once those neuron
patterns are
formulated they run automatically it's
part of something called your default
mode networ
work I'm one of these crazy guys that I
mean I always love that kind of stuff I
just you know it just kind of wakes you
up and you're like okay I get a little
adrenaline shot but sometimes it's hard
to get people to believe that it really
is just what you just said which is to
believe yeah I think people's
environment sucks I put it down to
environment man I think it starts with
self-awareness like knowing what you
want to do the book is called your one
word so knowing what your one word is is
really an exercise and self-awareness
but once you find it it's the
environment people may come across your
podcast Michael and say man that that
Michael's amazing had this great idea
and they go off and they're working for
the rest of the day hustling hard and
then they wake up the next day and that
drive and motivation is gone because
their environment sucks cuz their
environment keeps pulling them back down
to where they were before and so you
need to whatever you have that big
vision for yourself whatever it is like
I want to be the most successful Trader
in the world okay great you need to
start your day every day with resources
like read some of Michael's book or
listen to the podcast or watch an
interview or whatever it is to get get
you in that mindset that you can go and
accomplish that big thing because too
often the next day you're going to wake
up and everything's gone when you have a
goal in your head it's not even a goal
it's a fantasy it's a dream when you
have a book like this you can call it
your goal book and you write out your
goals and you go through I'm just about
to take you through bit by bit stage by
stage you go back to that but you can
look at it you can touch it you can just
make it real so remember if you do not
write out your goals as a plan and write
out how to accomplish them you don't
have a goal you have a wish you have a
dream you have a Daydream if you want to
go get a pen get a nice little book like
this you can do it on your phone too you
can make a document in your
computer and be prepared to make your
goals real so let's start now get your
book pause this if you need to go and
find one create one and I want you to
pick a goal and do not even start with I
want to lose £5 I want more money these
are what I call Wishy Washi goals no if
you can make your goals real you might
as well make them huge big enormous
phenomenal so if you say well I want
more money that's my go oh hang on a
minute hey I got $10 here there you go
you go well that's not my goal but you
said I want more money and I learned
this when I used to work with women who
were infertile that come in they go you
know I just want to be pregnant I want
to be pregnant so bad if I was just
pregnant I go well as I look at your
notes you've been pregnant six times I
know I keep
miscarrying so being pregnant is not
your goal is it what isn't your goal to
carry to fullterm a healthy robust
bouncing baby to deliver a perfect baby
to be a great mom yeah that's my goal
why didn't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants explosive gas so
let's start with a big goal pause if you
need to take some time open your book
and write out a big goal you can have a
career goal on whatever I'm going to
have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow in loving and
respecting each other and you can have a
health goal but I want you to pick one
only one not three not five not one goal
it can be career can be Health can be
love pick one goal and then I want you
to decide why you want that goal so much
so the first thing is I have a goal I
want to have my own business that's my
goal and now you're going to go to a
next page and write out why do you want
to have your own business so much and
the more reason you can write out why
the more
likely you will make that goal real so
write down why write down as many y's as
you can and
remember you can come back any time to
this and think oh I've thought of
another why and another why so leave
plenty of space take your time and when
you've done your wise go to another page
and write out who will benefit from you
achieving that goal of course you will
but who who will benefit for instance if
you have your own business you will
employ people who will benefit maybe
your kids will go to private school
maybe your business will allow you to
help your partner have their business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have to achieve that goal so write
out who will benefit from you achieving
go who how and why will they benefit
you're going to buy your mama house put
your niece and nephew through private
school you you think of your mind as
like the genie in the bottle that says
your wish is my
command and I want you to understand
that every thought you think and every
word you say is a blueprint that your
mind body and psyche must make real so
when you write out your goals don't say
I wish I could be rich I long to be in a
loving relationship write it as if it's
already happening I am a millionaire I
am in a loving relationship you're might
go well that doesn't make sense it does
make sense because your mind only works
in the present tense
when you say next year I'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is and so you must write your goals
in the present tense I am I always I
have I do this new page is about your
discipline how many hours a day you
going to spend working on your
goal how often are you going to come
back to this book and look at it I want
you to write out I am I
always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in you see the best goal in
the world will not work if you don't
work and many people fail at this point
they write out a goal my goal is to be a
millionaire my goal is to be famous my
goal is to be wildly in love and they
think that's it it's not it if you want
to be madly in love right at all the
reasons why but then you have got to put
yourself in front of the kind of person
you want to share your life with if you
want to start your own business and you
have a reason why you also need to have
the discipline to meet people who will
fund you sponsor you joint venture with
you so I want you to really understand
that the best goal will not work if you
don't work you can have the start point
but you have to keep going many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther vandros had a
goal to be a
rockar and people said well you're an
overnight success he would I don't think
so you know I sang Jingles for KFC for
12 years that's a long night 12 years
and people said but Luther you're
singing on television that's cool get
paid a lot of money for KFC said yeah
but it's not my goal and he stuck it out
and many people have got so close to
success and had to keep going and you
have to keep going
so look at your discipline and decide
you will give more to your goal give
even more work on it look at it write it
out think about it talk about it you
must be prepared to give so much to your
goal in fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
I don't want to share three things with
you that I truly believe in this
manifestation thing now I'm not that
Voodoo um The Law of Attraction guy but
I can tell you images uh pictures
walking in on something looking at uh
looking at other possibilities getting
examples of other people doing things is
so so valuable I mean it's our first way
to learn is to mimic is to see as babies
are are you know we see our
parents playing with their phones guess
what we want to pick up the phone and
play with the phone we see our parents
typing on the computer compu the kids
want to do what they want to come type
on your computer they don't even know
how to use it yet it's mimicking it's
basically taking something else somebody
has done boom Boat Boat I want boat okay
it's the way we learn to cook you watch
your mom cook eggs or fry bacon or make
oatmeal and she's got her own recipe
guess what that's the recipe you use so
we end up with all these little twerks
and weird habits uh back in the 50s you
know all all our parents smoked so what
happened when the kids grew up they
picked up smoking and alcohol Etc so the
first thing to do is on the
manifestation thing is you got to have
some pictures right if you don't have
those
pictures you know you don't you have
poverty around you you have struggle you
have like I grew up in struggle I didn't
grew up in poverty I grew up in a
struggle even though we had enough okay
it was always this idea that there
wasn't enough even when there was enough
it was crazy even when we had enough
dude it was always this idea that we
didn't have enough and I keep moving
around around on this because I want you
guys to see these views they're just
ridiculous beautiful little town of
poano that is filled with
magic okay and for those of you who've
never traveled here or been over this
part of the world man come over here
figure out literally sit down this one
of the things I do first I take a lock
in on a picture bang yacht second thing
I'm going to do is try to get as close
to that thing on the manifestation thing
not the Law of Attraction but the law of
action okay first I see it then I'm
going to try to get I'm going to close
the distance now it took me 20 years to
get on this this Beast okay but what I
can do in between then and I hope it
doesn't take you 20 years is I'd started
collecting pictures and images okay
until I could actually put my feet on
get as close as you can between you and
the target so if it's a boat a plane uh
a business business ownership an RV a
car whatever it is okay what you want to
do is take pictures of it collect image
of it okay maybe reinforce those by
looking at them often thinking about
them just playing with it don't even
worry about how to get it uh what it's
going to take to get it and the second
thing is to start like closing the
distance between you and that image
could be pictures could be images could
be research it could be you going to the
car dealership and actually sitting in
the car you know getting an appointment
to go see the house I
remember this is insane to think this
but I remember when I did not
think that I could get somebody to show
me a house I remember when I was like I
was lan and I went out late I wanted to
see this house that was for sale and I
was concerned that they wouldn't think
enough of me to even let me see the
house so if you guys have ever struggled
with all this limited thinking okay but
later I bought the house I was Lally
bought the house ended up making on that
house I made like $12 million or
something and I did did not think when I
went into the house that I was going to
be able to even see the house so if you
suffer from a self-esteem issue
um
or sense of self or I was telling my
daughter the other day I said man I've
had self-esteem issues my whole life not
thinking I was good enough not thinking
I could get there I'm still doing it
today you know I started thinking about
you know last time I was here 20 years
ago one day I'm going be on a boat here
the posto now I'm thinking one day I'm
going to be here on my own boat what do
you want to be on okay so number one
okay take a picture of it two close the
distance and three at some point you're
going to have to start doing the math
and the math for me is this what would
it take to buy this what is the
resources the beans the coins the
dollars the energy the output the number
of people I need to make contact with
and if I can't figure that out just
figure this simple math out how
did
uh he do it how
did he do it how did he do it what
business are they
in what did they do to do this how did
they get it and maybe it's just a
charter okay so nothing wrong with that
okay hope you guys do well hope you
figure out some things that really get
rich in your mind about your
manifestations about what you want what
your purpose is what's driving you to
fuel you so you can and your you and
your family can have a great life if you
ever get to post a
tunnel okay let me know the reason why
visualization and picturing yourself
succeeding and allowing yourself to feel
the happiness and the pride that comes
with picturing a positive future the
reason why that's is important is let's
say Shelly does that every single day
this week every day she wakes up she
walks for five minutes and as she's
walking on that treadmill she's
visualizing herself finishing a 10K in 6
months and how proud she is every every
time she does that she is changing
what's going on up
here this isn't something I made up this
is true and it's not only true based on
science but let's think about this from
a common sense perspective if Shelly
wakes up or if you wake up every single
morning and instead of thinking about
the worst case instead of looking at
your body in the mirror and going I'm so
fat I'm so out of shape I'll never run a
10K this never going to happen why
didn't I exercise last year I hate my
flabby stomach I hate my my big thighs I
hate how out I'm embarrassed to go like
if that's what you're
thinking then that is what you're
allowing your brain to continue to
filter the world through if you start
teaching yourself the skill of
visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now is you start
to think like the kind of person that
does a 10K if after an entire week what
Shelley does is she get looks in the
mirror and she goes I'm getting stronger
every day I'm really proud of myself
even though I'm I'm feeling flabby I'm
not saying you're flabby shell but even
though I'm feeling flabby I'm doing the
work I can do this what happens a week
from now is when she sees a registration
for a
10K the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day the new mind just s to 10
days later is going to go oh wait a
minute I'm in sh I'm proud I'm doing
this why don't you sign up it's going to
filter the world in a very different way
because you're training it to this is
the heart of doing a mindset reset and
this is why visualization works and why
it's an important step and why I'm so
glad you're doing it the fact that we
are repeating the same patterns in many
cases of our our parents or even of our
own lives from the time we know 20 30 40
50 60 well what if you can go to the
Future and you can think about if I
could change my story today that would
get me to the Future that I want what
would the story say and in the book I've
given you some incises and some
exercises to start writing out your
story now you may think what do you mean
write out my story story I learned many
years ago to write out my money story my
life story my relationship story and
I've always started um in this fashion
I'm so happy and grateful for the fact
that I am living the life of my dreams
and I am traveling all over the world uh
first class and I um I'm able to give to
the Charities that my wife and I and
children love and I'm able to and I
write down in present tense everything
that I'm doing feeling experiencing for
health wealth relationships career
business finances fun experiences
charity I write down a page or two pages
that is a story that I want my future to
be like and then I type it out because I
usually write by hand I type it out and
then I laminate it then I'll record it
and then I'll listen to it over and over
and over again now you may think that
sounds silly why would you do that why
because any information that you get in
through the senses through your ears
through your eyes that you touch that
you feel activates neurons in the brain
when those neurons are activated and
they wire together if you repeat it
often enough your brain says hey hey
you're investing a lot of time and
energy on this stuff uh let me start to
put some automatic processes to make
that story real and this is where
winning from the inside out comes to
play this is why using meditation and
visualization and mindfulness and
affirmations and emotional man emotional
management techniques and subliminal
programming all work if you can get the
information into the brain and you have
spaced repetition backed with
emotion you are going to develop the
neural patterns that'll activate
something called
automaticity all right or automaticity
is when these neurons activate
automatically and then your perspective
changes your beliefs start to change
your behavior starts to change the
filters by which you see the world and
the lens by which you see the world
start to match up with the story one of
the first things we do in our win the
game of money program is we help people
program a new money story so they can
then earn the money they want and live
the life of their dreams why because it
works
visualization
um I don't know when it started I don't
have a tremendous amount of memory uh
some of you you know before high school
and and Middle School um my accident
when I was 19 years old really scrambled
my brains so I like some of you can
remember a lot in high school and middle
school and Elementary I'm one of those
people tremendous trouble accessing a
lot of that and just from a brain injury
and so I I don't remember where it
started but I do
remember uh at that
time somewhere in there I would just lay
in bed and visualize things I'd see
things
I I I'd think about going to school that
day and I would visualize things that
would happen at school sometimes just
fictional things you know here I am
walking up to that girl I like we're
having a great conversation we're making
out at my locker never happened don't
worry but you know they not all visual
I'm not the Law of Attraction guy
because I would have made out with all
the girls in high school didn't happen
just letting you know Law of Attraction
screw you it didn't work you gota
actually talk to people anyway uh I
think that I developed this capacity to
visualize and see things and some of are
make believe stories and some of them
were just imagining how a situation
would
go and to this day including this
morning when I wake up I lay in bed and
I just kind of see what was maybe
already playing out if it was a dream I
just try to visualize and see what's
happening there or as soon as I become
conscious and I start thinking about the
day I imagine the day I imagine what's
what's on the docket for today I don't
look at my calendar I don't look at my
phone I just oh yeah I see something and
I imagine it going really
well and so as I see it and I imagine it
going well I also see it going
terrible and how I would deal with
it right so today uh I did not visualize
this situation I had this morning I
actually visualized some travel I have
travel later on this afternoon and so I
was thinking okay I have to travel
today I I want to have a calm energy as
I pack because usually I'm packing 90
miles an hour and I'm all frenetic
getting out of the house I don't want to
do
that uh okay I'm gonna be on that gonna
be a car ride today so I'm seeing myself
on the car I'm talking to some people
all right you know I'm G to call some
family and friends today in the car ride
over to the airport
and I just I visualize or sometimes it's
not you know the dream or the day it's
I've been stewing on a big goal or dream
something big upcoming maybe it's a huge
Stadium speech or maybe I'm G to talk
with this particular you know influencer
in the world who I want to have a
positive impact with and I'll visualize
that going well and not well it's like
if I was visualizing a marathon I would
visualize all the training up to it I'd
visualize that first starting kickoff
point I'd visualize mile 12 when my legs
feel like they're going to fall off I'd
visualize watching people past me and
how I would feel about that and what I
would tell myself in a positive way to
keep running I would visualize myself
then finally hitting the Finish Line
celebrating with it going out that night
doing the ice bath and waking up the
next day feeling fulfilled the whole
life cycle of visualization is a habit
for me changed my life don't visualize
the wind visualize the whole life cycle
of the
activity
pre during post that's what most people
Miss in their visualizations most people
don't actually visualize they think
about something
briefly visualization is taking the time
to think about an activity a goal or a
dream and walking it through in your
mind beginning to end
not just the celebrations and good stuff
the hard stuff what you'll tell yourself
to survive to thrive to keep going
on some of some people
often hear the term visualization and
they think that's not me I don't
visualize and it's like I don't care if
you see it or not I wish we had a
different name for it we call it
imagination it's a mental process of
thinking through an act activity goal or
dream pre during and post the whole life
cycle all I want you to do don't worry
about if you can see everything
perfectly like learn to teach yourself
to see things more
visually but don't think that is a
component or requirement of
visualization let's just step back from
it has to be insanely visual because
people it's not very visual for me
that's fine I want you to think through
it let your brain do what it does
whatever think through it means to you
I'm using the same language for
visualization in that year when I was
really broken I was really broken I was
working at La Unified School
District I was miserable I was miserable
because I wasn't living in my dream I
was just doing a j o and then one day I
said what what do I need to do I I need
to I need to buy my
freedom that's what I need to do I need
to buy my freedom well I don't know
about buying my freedom I don't know
about buying I don't know about having
money saved up my family didn't have
money saved up my mother used to tell me
oh this money is burning my pocket so I
know two things about money it's hot and
we can't keep it long we'd always have
one week where we had all the food in
the refrigerator and then one week where
we were the refrigerator was empty right
come on come on some of you guys know
about that to this day I spent so much
money on groceries you guys oh my God
it's like I'm feeding like a family of
10 cuz I'm so afraid of anybody ever
being at my house and being hungry
right and so I I wrote a check to
myself galani was
three
$110 I took it to the
bank well was
Fargo I started a new
account the next check I wrote
$125 and just like the first check I put
in the memo line funding my dream I
wasn't even clear what the dream was but
I knew there was something in my belly
who who in this room know you got
something in your belly it's something
I'm not even clear about it I don't know
how clear you are but I wasn't clear
about it but I knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for La
Unified School District and no
disrespect to La Unified School District
it just wasn't my
destiny I wrote another check in two
weeks
$146
funding my dream now I started mailing
the checks in because I didn't want to
see my
balance cuz I don't want to go
shopping cuz I you going to repeat what
you learned right until you decide to
not repeat what you learned so I mailed
the check in and then I wrote another
check and I wrote another check and
every check I wrote I made sure it was
5% more than the first check the ne the
previous check I sold my Tima I had a
car note sold my Tima bought a clunker
cuzz it didn't have a car note now I can
write a bigger check fun in my dream I
moved out of my three-bedroom three bed
three bath house and moved in became a
roommate with my friend who smoked I put
towels at the base of the door so the
smoke wouldn't come through the door I
was willing to be inconvenienced are you
yes I'm just saying I'm just I'm just
showing you the story I just the charge
I just gave you I stopped get getting my
hair done that was when I started going
natural I I stopped going out I I
stopped going out dancing I stopped
going out to dinners my family didn't
know what was going on they thought oh
my God you know it's La she's on drugs
but she's not losing weight so maybe not
I don't know what's going
on I kept writing bigger checks to
myself $900
$900 I mailed it to W Fargo funding my
dream
$1,100 mailed it to w Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what the
dream
was I just knew I had one and it was
being borne through me and I needed to
give it a
chance that's all I knew you don't have
to see 2,000 feet in front of you just
see
200 and run to the
200 yes yes yes yes you don't have to
see it all three and A2 years later I'd
written a check to myself every two
weeks for three and 1/2
years I didn't go out for three and a/2
years I didn't go dancing I get didn't
get my hair done I didn't get my nails
done for three and a half years are you
willing to be
inconvenience for your
conviction I walk in to Wells Fargo
three and A2 years later and I said hi
God bless you hi my name is Lisa Nichols
she go oh my God
you're the fun in my dream lady I was
like yeah I guess I am and all of a
sudden all the tellers came running
around the manager came they're like oh
my God okay oh my God we have been
wondering we all got the same question
y'all know what the questions right
what's your
dream I was like
um I'm not sure but I know that it
includes inspiring people
having people believe in themselves
again teaching them how to get back up
when they've been knocked
down having them to be willing to give
themselves a thousand Second Chances and
every time they get to 9.99 press
reset I'm not sure what it's going to
look like but it's just going to help
people I said I came to check my balance
I've been writing a few checks to you
guys I say yes you've been writing a lot
I said I just want to check my balance
you don't know your balance I said no I
got this really big stack of summary
bank statements at home cuz my mama said
money Burns her pockets and I don't want
it to burn my pocket I wanted to pay for
my
freedom I said I just came to see what
my balance was if I had enough to fund
my dream as it gets clear she wrote it
down everyone's excited she wrote it
down turned it around to me I looked at
it I said oh no my name is Lisa shant
Nichols and my social security number I
said that is not my money and I am not
taking that money cuz you're probably
going to want it back so just fix that
error right
now and they looked at me they said you
really don't think that's yours I said
no my family's never had $5,000 in the
bank or $10,000 in the
bank that's
$62,500
in the bank
they said Miss Nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up they said Miss Nichols
whatever your dream
is I think you can fund it now I looked
at my son gilani who now was five or six
and I said
jalani our lives are going to be a
little different now baby jalani said
yeah Mommy can
we can we now go to
McDonald's see for 3 years I've been
telling Jani I'll make you a Big Mac
Mama makes Big Macs better than
McDonald's and so it began with $110
check so I don't know what yours is I
don't know what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here right yes yes and this is the
beginning yes this is the beginning of
your radical this is the this is the the
be the next best step this is the first
step and so I just stop by to let you
know you're on the right path and and as
you ramp up as you ramp up you're going
to have questions you're going to be
afraid I do more things afraid now than
I do
Fearless cuz the bigger you play the
bigger your
breakdowns every single one of my errors
in The Last 5 Years have cost me six
figures like every single one
every single one of my errors has
required me to call an
attorney like they're just big cuz I'm
playing
big I'm playing big so be willing to go
to the
edge and this is where you are here be
willing to go to the
edge and not just lean
over and feel the
breeze and watch the people
jump and watch them soar and look
through the windows at all the people
who are living great lives don't just go
to the edge and feel it be willing to
lean feel your heartbeat feel it that
lets you know you're alive that lets you
know you're okay fear fuels you fear
lets you know go get more information
fear let you know step a little later
and study fear let you know get up a
little little earlier fear let you know
ask for help fear is informing you it's
not stopping you it's just another
emotion like love and compassion and
gratitude we just made it paralyze us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear I feel it and I'm moving
forward anyway I feel it and I'm going
to love anyway I feel it and I'm going
to invest in me anyway I feel it and I'm
going to show up and play anyway when
you get connected with fear it becomes
your best friend and when you stand on
the
edge you feel the
breee you feel the
fear and you leap anyway
fulfillment is when you're
satisfied because you are fully
developing your deepest
desires and your character fulfillment
is very different than happiness
everybody happiness comes and goes
happiness is fleeting happiness is like
the waves in an ocean or the waves on
Lake Michigan the Great Lakes here in
the United States which is where I grew
up on Lake Michigan the waves they come
and they go right that's happiness it
comes and it goes it rolls in and out of
your life and often times it feels like
it's out of your
control fulfillment is the ocean or the
Great Lakes
itself fulfillment is something way
deeper and
fulfillment is about
integrity and meaning and the fact that
when you have integrity and meaning in
your life you are fulfilled
you are
satisfied because you are fulfilling and
fully developing your deepest
desires and your
character and this is important and I'm
GNA really Hammer these words around
meaning and more importantly
Integrity if I had to pick one word that
was important when it comes to you
deepening your level of fulfillment with
your whole
life the word is integrity now this was
brand new to me you know I always
thought about fulfillment like oh find
your joy find your passion find your
purpose like then you'll be fulfilled do
things that you love you'll be fulfilled
it actually has more to do with
Integrity which is really cool and you
know when I explain why Integrity is so
important it's also going to illuminate
all the places in your life where you're
not fulfilled because I guarantee you
the places in your life where you're
missing fulfillment are also lacking
personal
Integrity you're not
operating consistently with what you
care about you're not operating with
Integrity in terms of your values you're
not spending your time your energy and
your resources on what truly aligns with
you from an Integrity standpoint and so
that's why we're going to continue to
hammer this word integrity okay and
that's great because when you start to
think about cultivating personal
integrity and how that translates to
more fulfillment in your life it's going
to make that fulfillment something that
you can cont control it's going to make
it deeply personal it's going to make it
something that you can move the needle
on it puts the locus of control within
your reach let me talk about the two
mistakes that everybody makes okay when
it comes to fulfillment and this is why
fulfillment in some areas of your life
are Out Of Reach right now number one
the number one mistake that we make if
you're struggling with fulfillment in
any area of your life is that you're not
living according to your own
values you know I think we've all gone
through those periods of Our Lives where
we are drinking too much or spending too
much money or we're hanging out with the
wrong people or we're making unhealthy
choices and you know deep down inside
that this is not what you want to be
doing it's not what you should be doing
but because you are not living based on
your own values you don't respect
yourself there's no way you are going to
live a fulfilled life if at the base
level you don't respect the choices that
you're making so can you identify an
area your life right now either in the
chat or in the journal uh function in
the app an area of your life where you
are not living according to your own
values I see Health coming up for people
I'm sure if you think about how you're
spending your money or whether or not
you're saving money you're not aligned
with your values maybe you're doing work
I see productivity I see exercise so if
you're not living according to your own
values this is one reason why you're not
going to be fulfilled in your life the
second thing is that you spend your time
and your resources on things that
actually don't matter to
you you're spending your time and your
resources on things that don't matter to
you at the deepest level these are the
two big mistakes that we all make and
the good news here is that these are
mistakes that you can easily identify
that you can address and when you do you
take control back and you will amp up
the level of fulfillment that you feel
I'm going to say this
again fulfillment is not the same thing
as
happiness fulfillment is meaning and
integrity and that's why habit number
one and building a foundation is about
values because you will only find
fulfillment true lasting deep
fulfillment everybody if you are
following your values like a compass
not your mood you got to follow your
values and let that be your compass
that's how you build the proper
foundation and so what does that mean
what does that mean everybody well it
means you got to figure out what matters
to you okay and then you must develop
the simple
discipline to spend your time and energy
on things people experience iences that
align with what matters to
you living with Integrity to what
matters to you is the secret of
fulfillment and I think you know i' I've
alluded to this earlier but you know I
can think about times in my life when
either what I was doing for work or what
I was doing with my free time did not
align with my values to overcome the
body takes a will that's greater than
the program to to no longer get up and
run through the same routine that you do
every day and your body wants in the
middle of meditation saying quit I'm too
tired you got too many texts you got too
many emails you got too many things to
do the body's been programmed to get up
and go and you and you say wait wait
wait wait wait a second here we're not
going anywhere until I get clear on who
I want to be today and every time you
execute that will that's greater than
the program people say oh I'm I can't
meditate actually you're doing it right
actually that's why it's hard because it
you're actually that is the process
right there there's no such thing as a
bad meditation what you're doing is
actually exactly what you need to do and
every time you do that you become
conscious that you go unconscious that's
how you actually develop the skill of
Consciousness it's not being conscious
it's catching yourself when you go
unconscious and people if they can see
thinking is the unconscious essentially
conscious is connecting to everything
which is in the space of nothingness
really but there's a journey to get
there and if you're patient with
yourself and you see that as a
victory like oh you start getting
aroused you start getting frustrated you
think I can't do this and you go oh no
no no no no no no we're not going to
quit here that would be me getting up as
the same person I'm curious what's on
the other side of this frustration you
settle your body back down into the
present moment you unfold back into that
Eternal space I'm telling you every time
you do that it's a victory you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind then it actually
turns out that the body starts
liberating energy it starts re
liberating energy but like an unbridled
stallion it goes oh really you think
that's all you think that's all you have
watch this and then it gets starts
bringing up memories of the past and all
of that just to feel an emotion and if
you're aware that it's doing that and
you settle it down you're you're taming
the animal you're teaching it you're
you're teaching it how to to change its
state right and guaranteed if you keep
doing that you walk out in your life I
guarantee you'll be less responsive and
reactionary to everyone and everything
so in seven days we see that not only
there dramatic biological changes to
suggest that the person for
environment but it it goes for the
majority of people that immerse
themselves and going all in and what
does that mean a different environment
they're in a ballroom they're in a
ballroom been to thousands of ballrooms
there's nothing really exciting in a
ballroom what's exciting in a ballroom
they all look the same but the data
suggests that they're in a whole new
environment where where is that where is
that taking place it's taking place from
within the person closed eyed internal
world is
everything open usually happiness exists
as part of the play of opposites you
experience the happiness because
something makes you happy and then that
thing that made you happy either leaves
you or the very thing that made you
happy suddenly makes you
unhappy marriage for
[Music]
example or a
relationship before you start living
together you're happy when you start
living together you
unhappy so what is if it's not happy
what are we talking about
the there's
a if
you let go of thinking and remain as the
awareness then there is in that that
awareness emanates a certain peace
alive
peace joy peace a
peaceful joyful sense of
aliveness inner peace maybe a better
word and happiness but one would have to
add to it it's an alive piece it's not
the piece of uh having deadened yourself
to
emotions or anything like that it's an
alive intensely alive piece you can
sense it even if it's only just a
glimpse right
now surrender
thought and of
course right now if you're not thinking
about the problems of your life there
are no problems in this moment there's
only a sense of beingness or
liveness
and that is the connectedness with
being and so you transcend the Opposites
between happiness and
unhappiness to learn to rewire your
negative programming check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there it turns out science has
recognized that when you fall in love
you stop playing the programs and you
start creating from your conscious mind
wishes and desires are conscious mind
and so once you let go of a program and
you start creating